ja in ordnung nicht reagieren noch mal
auf dollar nachdem meine beiden ersten
reaktionen auf diese wundervolle
beziehung dame nachdem die beiden
reaktionen bei euch sehr sehr sehr sehr
gut ankamen habe ich mir heute das video
rausgesucht das perfekte dinner hat
dominik endlich dein leben in den griff
das wird wieder wahnsinn wie immer bevor
wir uns das video anschauen werde ich
euch einige kommentare hintereinander
vorlesen um einen kleinen vorgeschmack
schon mal zu geben
sie ist das denn hier ein leid gleich
ein kilo weniger doppel ach du scheiße
wer hat denn da mal geschwängert sommers
haare sind so fertig wie fritteusenfett
wann kommt zucker in einen wurstsalat
sie kann irgendwie auch keine haare
waschen oder die dome ist so fett machen
als sport und esse weniger meine
mitschüler weinen wenn sie als dumme
beleidigt werden
ja wir schauen mal in die folge 1 2
sekunden und fressen robert was sagst du
dazu rückt haben ist so fett eher schul
foto aus der ersten klasse druckt immer
noch ja das könnte tatsächlich sein dass
ja alles haben wir schon in meiner
ersten wirklichen aufgabe gesehen also
wie sie zu hause sind ist und hansi
mariano rumkommt aber ab hier räumt
dollar halt auf und ab da schauen wir
jetzt mal weiter als süßigkeiten
aufräumen einfach aufessen füßen nur
wenige minuten später alles aufgeräumt
sie hat auch ein neues laptop case
übrigens okay die dame war einkaufen er
tatsächlich auch obst gekauft und
knacker würstchen und zwei scheiben
fleischwurst
mal schauen was die doppel gala dinner
kochen wird
in drei gänge menü
vorspeise chips hauptgang schokolade und
nachtisch dann fleisch wurst was ist
denn hier ja so stolz auf dich
hey willst euch vorstellen dommel
einheit aus 26 und die tante marianne
streichelt die soll sagt soja
superklasse haste aufgeräumt die ist ja
keine zehn mehr so positiv überrascht
fürs wohnzimmer sauber autobahn solange
keine süßigkeiten rum der tisch war
sauber hammer war so stolz auf euch
diese stimme von der marianna auch so
ein bisschen ich finde es irgendwie
immer wahnsinnig durfte er zu zuhören
weil die immer so eine komische betonung
auf hatte aber ich will jetzt mal
endlich sehen wie dumme da jetzt hier
kocht 8
ja
also ich hatte ja fleischwurst eh schon
aber dann in solchen mengen 8
das ist ihr arm ich dachte das wär ich
[Musik]
dachte dass hier wäre eine fleischwurst
es tut mir leid weil sie sehen sollte es
einem sorry und die marianne erwartet da
jetzt so richtig krassen salat vorher
nein jetzt auch noch von fetten ich sag
euch das wirten ich sag euch vor allem
das wird so eine wurst käse salat und
was haben wir in kommentaren gesehen
wahrscheinlich um noch zucker mit rein
[Musik]
da war doch was ist das lese oder was
also die zutaten für dom ist vorspeisen
salate inhalten bisher fleisch wurst
käse und mayonnaise ja vollkommen in
ordnung also das ist ja wirklich ganz
armes deutschland zucker einkommen geben
doch die marie a b wartet auf ihr essen
geil geil
das ist ein vorspeisen wie man sich ihn
vorstellt ich bin so krass auf mariannes
reaktion gespannt
ich mache hat einen deftigen kost salat
schmeckt einfach nur süß das ist doch
nicht die nachspeisen ein alter das kann
ja gar nicht sehen du gott das war
bratenfett was ich dachte es bei
mayonnaise brand werde sehr doch
schlimmer also rang 16
ja
die feier ist variable echt übertrieben
mein leben ist das noch nicht passiert
dass ich irgendwo salat gegessen hat wo
so viel zucker und vor allem rat nicht
drin war
er war ja eine betonung geraten
naja du bist wirklich wenn hier meint
mein vorbild elon musk ist bist du hier
und doch ist halt jetzt kommt die
hauptspeise und sie macht hier wieder
ordentlich käse sogar diesmal in die
mikrowelle
hier hat sie wieder ordentlich küsschen
mitberaten vertraten verein sie schmeckt
das ganz normal ab ich kann kann es
nicht mehr sehen von einer es hier jetzt
noch obotan mit rein kommt für den zwei
toren kann ich echt kauf dass ihre
fertiggericht hat was nur warm machen
aus dass man wenigstens etwas
genießbares auf den teller
also ich meine ich bin das ja alles
witzig aber die kleine hier die tut mir
echt ein bisschen leid kleines
unschuldiges mädchen und anstatt das mit
wichtigen nährstoffe und mineralien
versorgen gekriegt dass eine vorspeise
und wurstsalat zum hauptgang auch
nochmal irgendwo es mit jesu und
nachteile
als ich bin echt gespannt auf den
nachtisch wird erwartet die dann von mir
dass ich ein sternekoch wert auf einmal
oder was ja ich muss da glaube ich
nichts mehr zu sagen also das ist hier
wirklich weniger punkte vergeben müsste
da müsstest du mir noch welche rausgeben
marianna zu trockene geile kommentare
sechs den jetzt weitergehe katastrophe
war nur aus festgestanden habe ich
gedacht dass meine küche wie bei jeder
reaktion auf dauer also ich habe immer
tränen in den augen ich muss so viel
wasser trinken oder was damit sagen
würde cola ich einfach so ein
flüssigkeitsverlust hey das ist ja
wahnsinn die kocht und frisst er bei
gummibärchen gequetscht und ich hoffe
das ist nicht schlechter als nachtisch
damit kann sie ja wahrscheinlich auch
nichts falsch machen weil das ist ja
fährt also die dame macht jetzt hier das
creme brulée sich kräuter noch zucker
darüber jetzt mit dem bunsenbrenner so
ganz normal wie man creme brulée halt
macht
doch ich dachte ehrlich gesagt dass ich
noch wurst ins creme brulée macht aber
dass sie ihre tasche in brands hatch
werde jetzt wirklich gedacht kann
flambieren war kurz abgelenkt und auf
einmal habe ich nur das knistern gehört
doch pfarrer marian tasche marianne matt
das menü ist noch offen fahrgäste auch
noch marianne tasche ab und das wurde
sowieso viel stress mit einem pass auf
die frage wie wir das machen braucht es
doch bloß nicht alles mist
ich weiß dass das alles nur gespielt es
wahrscheinlich aber das ist so geil
gespielt aber hier mein liebes mädchen
wird sich jetzt richtig gravierend was
ändern das war es die kumpels umstyling
krieg endlich dein leben in den griff
family stories er sei mehr aus
also doch ist wirklich schlimmer als
alle hilf mir folgen zusammen
anders hätte mich das heutige video ist
allerdings auch beenden meine liebe
lucio wenn es euch gefallen hat meine
reaktion hierauf damit die dritte
reaktion mittlerweile schon anlass einen
daumen hoch da meine lieben freunde
schaffen wir 50.000 like ich glaube das
sollten wir hinkriegen und wenn ihr das
schaf da kommt tatsächlich in einer
woche eine reaktion von mir auf dommel
wie sie einen kindergeburtstag ist wenn
ich auch schon gespannt was da abgeht
dann war ich auch ganz kurz eine
kleinigkeit sagen uns was mir
aufgefallen dass über 60 prozent also
zwei von drei leuten von euch die gerade
dieses video anschauen nicht abonnent
sind von meinem kanal klickt auf
abonnieren werdet offizieller teil der
doku und klickt auf die glocke dann
bekommt die benachrichtigung wenn ich
was neues hoch lade und jetzt kommt das
a drauf
[Musik]